ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen ich bin hin der
letzte folge hingegangen oder ein
ja wir gehen auch heute auf jeden fall
wieder zurück nach hause die sache ist
allerdings dass ich mich erst mal auf
dieses dorf hier konzentrieren wollte in
der letzten folge waren ja hier
stehengeblieben haben eine riesige
entdeckungstour gemacht und sind bei den
halben ort sie angefahren und ich habe
mir noch gar nicht dieses dörflein hier
angeschaut hier haben wir nur kartoffeln
drin
wir haben auch noch äpfel und den
löwenzahn pro da gehen wir auf jeden
fall auch noch runter ich will ein paar
diamanten
das hast du dir selbst eingebrockt wir
gehen auf jeden fall nachher noch in die
höhle hier runter denn das ziel für die
heutige wie somit ist das wie diamanten
finden ihn zuvor möchte ich allerdings
ganz kurz das dorf mir hier so ein
bisschen genauer anschauen denn das ist
ja wirklich extrem riesig und vielleicht
finden wir hier sogar schon so ein paar
wertvolle gegenstände wir haben vorne so
ein kleines blumenbeet wir haben hier
vorne noch an holztischen hier rein von
der seite oder von hinten genau von hier
geht es hier ein hier ist allerdings
auch nichts drin haben hier vorne noch
ein häuschen sogar mit dieser keramik
wieder am rand also nicht nur wie die
anderen häuser mit diesem bruchstein
hier haben wir allerdings auch nichts
von ihr sind überall keine kisten
wir entdecken dass wir auf jeden fall
erstmal heute so ein bisschen und die
letzten episoden das habt ihr auch
gesehen gingen alle also zumindest die
letzten acht oder neun über 20 minuten
und ich weiß auch noch ganz zu beginn
des projekts da war die xxl höhe in
folge einfach über 20 minuten lang und
nicht mehr so voll wie lange folge und
so weiter und so fort und jetzt
mittlerweile ist was jede folge seien
deswegen möchte ich die heutige folge
auf jeden fall ein bisschen kürzer
halten hier waren wir glaube ich sogar
schon drin da vorne waren wir auch schon
drin hier hinten sind wir auch schon
rein gelaufen
ich möchte auf jeden fall nochmal hier
vorne waren wir noch nicht
die heutige episode wird auf jeden fall
bisschen kürzer sein denn ich hab mir
gesagt sobald ich diamanten finde wie
die heutige folge enden auf der einen
seite ich mache ihnen mal den weg hier
ein bisschen schöner sehr blöd dass der
hier total kaputt ist an so vielen
stellen
ich hab mir auf der einen seite halt
gedacht ja auch hier die folge kann dann
relativ kurz gehen also es kann sein
dass wir direkt diamanten finden
es kann allerdings auch eine sehr lange
folge werden falls wir lange zeit keine
diamanten finden sollten geht's hier
vorne
[Musik]
das ist balu das ist mir auch
aufgefallen aber ich habe jetzt auch
keine knochen dabei um den zu holen ich
hab noch eine schatzkarte
[Applaus]
brauche ich die schatzkarte er keine
ahnung ob ich die aus dem tiger ist
schon geil aus wieder da hinten am
horizont schild ich weiß nicht ob ich
diese schatzkarte irgendwo aus sondern
unter wasser festung mitgenommen habe
dass er jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht
vergessen
ich werde mir allerdings auf jeden fall
erstmal eine kiste machen und ein paar
sachen hier sichern denn wenn wir jetzt
darunter in die höhe gehen macht auf
jeden fall keinen sinn wenn man inventar
komplett voll ist deswegen erstmal ein
bisschen holz holen bzw
habe ich sogar holz mit am start dann
machen wir uns auch erst mal ganz kurz
eine werkbank die setzt jetzt einfach
mal wir machen uns ein kleines lager wo
ziehen wir dann einig dass wir ziemlich
vorne ein damit wir vorne auch direkt in
die höhle runter gehen können also wie
vorhin bereits gesagt es kann sein dass
die heutige folge zu dem kursus ihr seht
ja wahrscheinlich schon daran wenn ihr
euch einfach mal die video länge anguckt
aber auf der anderen seite kann es auch
sein dass sie sehr lang wird wenn wir
nämlich keine diamanten finden sollten
also erstmal alles reinpacken was wir
wirklich nicht brauchen haltbarkeit drei
eigentlich eine sehr geile verzauberung
packen wir auf jeden fall noch was
anderes mal drauf eine schere benötige
ich glaub ich nicht buch auch nicht
karotten ein bisschen was zu essen ist
immer ganz gut gebrauchen wir nicht
milch einmal wegen effekten ist
vielleicht ganz sinnvoll immer noch mal
ein bisschen mehr essen mit und was ich
auch noch mitnehmen sind auf jeden fall
die feile ich habe allerdings keinen
kuchen und meine fackeln
[Musik]
also hier vorne geht es runter in die
höhe
hier vorne gibt ich nehme hier vorne
erst mal die ganze kohle mit denn bei
unserer insel zu hause können wir mit
dem willinger der im baumhaus schild
extreme gut kohle gegen smaragd ich bin
schon tot bevor ich überhaupt der höhle
angekommen bin wir können auf jeden fall
mit dem villa der bei uns zu hause in
der höhle schild nicht in der höhle ich
schwer freunde auf der spur silber gar
keine monster näher weil wahrscheinlich
auch die sonne von oben ranch und ich
habe keine ahnung wo wir hier lang
laufen sollen ich werde allerdings auf
jeden fall die komplette kohle mitnehmen
denn und das wollte ich gerade schon
sagen wir haben hier den villiger bei
uns auf der insel oben im baumhaus drin
und er ist mittlerweile fischer experte
oder irgendwie so ich weiß nicht was
fischer mit kohle zu tun hat allerdings
gibt ja uns für neue kohle mittlerweile
schon einen smaragd dieses markt können
wir dann irgendwann beim
rüstungsschmiede und so auf unserer
villiger insel tauschen gegen diamant
gegenstände also gegen eine diamant
rüstung oder gegen diamant spitzhacke
oder irgendwie so und das ist ganz geil
denn dann brauchen wir zumindest nicht
mehr so viele diamanten für die ganzen
sachen allerdings finden wäre heute
vielleicht sogar noch diamanten die
sache ist nur dass wir jetzt gerade auf
der höhe hier und da seht ihr ja schon
da sind fast keine monster plus in der
höhle hier beziehen wir in der schlucht
hatten wir auch überhaupt keine lava am
start
sie haben einfach überhaupt keine tiefe
bisher erreicht und deswegen müssen wir
uns wahrscheinlich ein bisschen tiefer
runter bauen deswegen höre ich jetzt
einfach mal ob ich von irgendjemandem
hier ist auf jeden fall schon sehr laut
warum ich mir hier einfach runter
perfekt sagt jetzt hier kann man sich
diese über die erde runter bauen oder
[Musik]
okay wir sind in einer neuen hülle
freunde
hier vorne geht es nicht weiter ich
nimmer ganz kurz das eisen mit und dann
gehen wir mal hier um weiter wir haben
auf jeden fall war da vorne
hier ist auch noch eisen kohle davon
haben wir auch noch reisen das werde ich
gleich mitnehmen schneide ich euch
natürlich nicht alles einige vorne geht
es wohl noch gas runter aber noch menge
eisen und kohle
allerdings geht es hier erst mal nicht
weiter das erst mal weg
keine ahnung wo ich hier angekommen bin
allerdings haben wir eine schlucht
wieder in der schlucht entdeckt ich
werde mich allerdings erst mal ganz kurz
darauf konzentrieren dass ich hier meine
ganzen ärzte mit nehme ich das mal ganz
kurz zuvor noch eine fackel hin und hier
auch noch hier vorne geht es auf jeden
fall auch noch runter da fließt die lava
nämlich lang werde ich allerdings
vielleicht erstmal zu bauen ich nehme
erst mal wirklich die ganze kohle mit
und hier vorne jetzt noch mal eben das
eisen wir sehen allerdings schon das es
hier wirklich auch runter geht in die
schlucht also genau die gleiche seite wo
wir vorne lang gelaufen sind ist wohl
auch hier vorne die schlucht ich werde
erstmal hier hoch laufen dass hier erst
mal zu bauen und die lava hier zu bauen
so dass wir auf jeden fall hier nicht
noch rein fallen werden also hier ein
erde blog rein und jetzt können wir uns
auch mal so lang wie die lava brauchen
hier abzufließen
darauf konzentrieren hier vorne alles
ausleuchten bisher haben wir keine
creeper gesehen in dieser höhle nur
einige skelette und zombies sagt nun
bist tot
kommt jetzt die katze bis heute
unvergessen ist aber auch egal denn dann
konzentrieren wir uns jetzt nicht auf
das ganze eisen und die ganze kohle hier
und jetzt vielleicht erst mal auf unsere
höhle hier vorne ja mehr die lager
abgebaut ist auf jeden fall mittlerweile
schon mal leute hier das ist ein fehler
den ich jetzt wieder begangen habe ich
habe mir wirklich kein schild hier
wieder mitgenommen aber ich wusste auch
nicht dass wird auf unserer
entdeckungstour die sonne riesigen
höhlen abschnitt wieder entdecken hier
vorne ist ja die lava herunter geflossen
das habe ich abgebrochen
muss mich jetzt natürlich computer sagen
ich muss mich jetzt natürlich komplett
herunter bauen das hat natürlich wieder
nicht geklappt
allerdings haben wir keine spitzhacke
mehr deswegen müssen wir jetzt einfach
mit dem wenigsten hier irgendwie
auskommen ich setze jetzt mal über also
ein paar fackeln hin dass wir auf jeden
fall wissen wo wir schon waren wir sind
auf jeden fall keine diamanten da oben
ist gold ich kann ihn nicht abbauen also
jetzt selbst wenn ich jetzt jemanden
finden müsste ich erst mal noch mal kurz
hoch gehen um die abzubauen mit ziehen
müsste sogar eventuell nach hause fahren
erst mal das wasser zu bauen nach hause
fahren und mit glück spitzhacke holen
also meine diamant spitzhacke so dass
wir wenn wir diamanten finden die
wirklich auch vernünftig abbauen können
und eventuell sogar ein paar mehr
bekommen ihre mit stone
warum ihr das thema lieber ein bisschen
ein bisschen zu viel spaß das ist ja
irgendwie noch einfallen später oder so
[Musik]
wir haben hier wirklich alles am start
redstone reisen reisen kohle redstone
eisen lapislazuli und diamanten dass ich
immer eine fackel hingesetzt sie müssen
wir auf jeden fall noch abbauen im jetzt
ich gehe allerdings mal ganz kurz ein
bisschen weiter
das ist mal
und sollte schleunigst hier
es hat das eisenberger kannst du wo ich
alles in die luft fliegen sprachenlernen
double und da sind wir wieder oben
angekommen freuen ihr jedoch schon dass
die sonne gerade schon wieder aufgeht
denn ich könnte mir jetzt hier meine
schwarzenholz weiter nehme mir eine neue
eisen spitzhacke machen die sache ist
allerdings dass ich ja wirklich einfach
die dinge es brauche ich brauche die
glücks spitzhacke um hier die sache
vernünftig abbauen zu können deswegen
werde ich jetzt einfach mal tatsächlich
sogar alles mitnehmen bzw
so viel wie irgendwie geht und den rest
erst mal hier lassen das unwichtige und
daher lasse ich auch den löwenzahn hier
nehmen die wenn man das leder mit und
wie äpfel nämlich auch stattdessen
kabeljaus mit müssen wir noch mal ganz
kurz geben balu abholen der da vorne saß
um denen dann auf jeden fall auch noch
mitnehmen zu können die sache ist
nämlich dass ich keine lust habe dass er
dann irgendwie hier sitzt und dann
irgendwie die sporen oder so in die ecke
deswegen ganz kurz balu holen und euch
eine ganz kurze time ist wie ich
versuche zurückzufinden zu meiner insel
[Musik]
selbst mal eben kurz ende ich bin zwar
schon seit fünf minuten wieder unterwegs
aber guck mal wie schön das hier
aussieht mit dem sand der sich hier so
hoch zieht hier vorne mit diesem schwarz
eichenstamm blumenfelder dingsbums keine
ahnung wie das genau heißt aber das
sieht alles sehr sehr sehr sehr nice aus
ob wir vorne mit der bucht und so hier
vorne weil der ganze löwenzahn ich
glaube hier hatten wir ja das schwein
irgendwie hier vorne gerettet in der
letzten folge vom selbstmord ich werde
mich jetzt mal ganz kurz hier einsetzen
beziehungsweise bei blumen muss erstmal
ins brötchen rein perfekt sagte wir
gehen rein f5 und für euch jetzt noch
eine ganz kurze time deprimiert dort
hinten
ja ich hoffe wir finden eine insel
[Musik]
und da sind wir auch schon wieder zu
hause angekommen freunde es fühlt sich
echt so nach heimat hier vorne mit der
willicher insel hier rechts mit diesem
riesigen portal schwerter vorne im
hintergrund jetzt einfach mal hier vorne
kurz parken und jetzt können wir uns ja
auch mal hier den test angucken von
[Musik]
windows sparte schön recht gehabt freue
mich dass es trotzdem mal stehen damit
dirigent wie er sagt ja du warst halt
nicht da das hat mich geladen und so
weiter und wort ist jedoch da bescheid
wissen dass nichts damit zu tun hat also
das gras wächst nicht auf ganz normale
erde nicht perfekt ich hab ich auch
nicht müssen sehr gut
ich werde ganz kurz erst mal ein paar
sachen hier sichern ich habe allerdings
fast gar keinen platz mehr überall drin
deswegen ich werde erstmal ein bisschen
sogar cool hier gar nicht
kein bock drauf ich werde das hier erst
mal so ein bisschen eintauschen so dass
wir die kohle direkt mal wieder durch
getauscht haben kommt am 16
dadurch jetzt bekomme ich habe jetzt
einfach insgesamt 23 marco noch 20 mal
neues markt also insgesamt über 200
märkte und ich aber zwei diamanten das
heißt wir nehmen jetzt mal ganz kurz
unsere diamant spitzhacke wo habe ich
die denn reingepackt ist sie hier ist
sieht mit glück drei die muss ich
nämlich mal ganz kurz ein bisschen
verzaubern beziehungsweise reparieren
jetzt haben wir die auf jeden fall schon
mal halb voll und können damit die
diamanten abbauen das ist falsch
so möchte ich das machen die amboss
brauche ich nicht davon habe ich
ziemlich viele die mich einmal nämlich
wieder märkten weg kurz damit wie ich
mich fertig machen so ich bin fertig
ausgerüstet um wieder zurückzufahren und
die diamanten abzubauen allerdings seht
ihr schon dass ich hier friedhof
beziehungsweise grab insel noch mal eben
kurz an unsere schwarze wand hier machen
unser schwarzes brett
die sache ist das wieder von nichts
weiter angegangen sind wir dann wieder
das schaf geholt noch haben wir freunde
für das schwein gefunden die tiere insel
wird bald kommentieren sie bzw
bauminseln werde ich zusammen packen da
hinten hin dass die beiden schilder kann
ich auf jeden fall noch mal ganz kurz
abbauen und zusammen auf ein schreiben
dann sparen wir uns dann mich ein
bisschen was also tier insel baum insel
die wir zusammen kommen habe ich hier
noch blumeninsel irgendwo stehen ja
blumeninsel chicken nuggets
das werde ich auch auf die tier insel
machen denn ich möchte dass die tiere
sind alles zusammen beinhaltet also tier
insel baum insel und blumen
für chicken nuggets das macht glaube ich
mehr sinn denn sonnenblumen satz habe
ich mir ein attest welt getestet das
sieht einfach nicht schön aus wenn ich
die da hinten hin bauer das sieht viel
zu künstlich aus die jetzt mal
haarscharf perfekt dekker jetzt mal ganz
kurze runde penan gegangen hier vorne
mal wieder in unserem normalen hause
haben einige kritisierten luca die
gewinnerinnen dem bauch schlafen quartal
das portal da aussieht aber ja ich will
auf jeden fall dass dieses haus wieder
ein bisschen mehr an bedeutung gewinnt
wie haben hier fordern noch ganz viele
items drin
wie gesagt ist allerdings dass ich ein
bisschen zeitdruck habe ich hab in einer
viertelstunden termine der innenstadt
und ich brauchte eigentlich eine
viertelstunde hin
ich möchte allerdings unbedingt noch
zurück zur zu dem spot da hinten fahren
und die diamanten abbauen deswegen mal
ganz schnell eben die schilder hier drin
wieder gesichert und wir sprinten los
und fahren schnell rüber wieder zur
insel kürzung ganz wichtig so heimnetz
[Musik]
und da sind wir auch schon wieder hier
vorne beim festland angekommen in die
richtungen ihr seht schon ich habe die
tat beendet obwohl wir noch gar nicht
beim dorf sind allerdings nicht dass
hier wirklich viel zu schön mit diesen
booten und so und generell jetzt auch
hier vorne ich glaube da müssen wir
jetzt mal ganz kurz aus dem brötchen
aussteigen sagte sagt sagt das kann so
nicht so klappt auf jeden fall nehmen
das akazien boten mit und balu großes
brot
mappus weg hier vorne schwingt also die
ich glaube wir müssen jetzt kurz
aussteigen um hier vorne dann
weiterfahren zu können genau und balu
einmal bitte ganz kurz teleportieren
hier vorne uns brötchen rhein sehr gut
sehr gut sehr gut ist fast geschafft und
sagt alois drin und jetzt sieht ja auch
mal was sich hier vorne meine kuba mit
diesen booten und diesen diesem fluss
komme hier durch ihr könnt uns sonne
geile brücke bauen hier so durch dann
hast du hier so einen kleinen see kann
es hier weiter fahren nach vorne zum
schwein hier vorne mit den bergen da
hinten hier geht es dann wiederum komme
da hinten wie riesig diese berge sind
was geht denn jetzt ab plötzlich das ist
ja normal krass wir haben wir da oben
drauf da haben wir schafe auf jeden fall
am 10
also finde ich sehr sehr sehr schön im
werk allerdings glaube ich wenn ihr das
projekt schon ein bisschen länger
verfolgt der sich eigentlich alle sind
minecraft wunderschön finde und mir ist
es komplett egal ich bleib da kein essen
für dich mit deswegen naja ich finde
alles in minecraft wunderschön ich finde
das hier wunderschön also dieses ganz
normale weil mich das immer an diese
ganz frühen zeiten von minecraft
erinnert die vornahme auch noch eine
hülle die ignorieren wir allerdings erst
mal ich finde es allerdings auch schön
wenn man so riesige berge hat da kann
man auch geile sachen drin bauen die
beispielsweise sonnenhaus im berg oder
so mit so einer riesigen glaswand oder
so dann finde ich aber auch ganz geil
wenn wir diese savannah hat weil ich
finde der sache waren es gibt kein bio
ivo kummer hier gibt es ein waldbrand
ich finde es gibt kein bio wurden
sonnenuntergang oder sonnenaufgang so
schön aussieht wie nah savanne
ich finde aber auch hier vorne wenn man
sich das hier angucken sie prärie und
einfach so riesige felder und platz ohne
bäume hier vorne wieder den außenposten
einen großen bogen um auch das finde ich
wunderschön
also ich glaube aber wenn ich mich
entscheiden müsste was das schönste
minister dann sind es doch dann ist es
doch schon der ozean also einfach dass
man so was ist das da um alles wieder
erde also einfach dass wir so kleine
inseln haben wir haben komplette weiter
wo wir hin gucken können
das finde ich dann doch schon am ganzen
also ich bin total happy mit meiner welt
aber ich freue mich wirklich wenn man
irgendwann mal falls er bock drauf habt
gestaffelt 2 macht eine neue welt
anfängt oder so dass man dann sondern
natürlich selbstverständlich ein ganz
anderes die oma da freue ich mich auch
schon extrem drauf wir haben hier vorne
so kleine sehen die ich auch sehr schön
du gerade wieder hin teleportiert ich
hoffe dass ich hier gerade richtig laufe
und dass wir gleich bei dem dorf
rauskommen da sehen wir allerdings auch
schon und ich habe auch direkt meine
diamant spitzhacke am start das heißt
ich würde sagen wir gehen direkt runter
ich wollte mir eigentlich auch noch
einen wassereimer mitnehmen das habe ich
jetzt allerdings verpasst so dass wir
hier vernünftig runterkommen in die
höhle
die sache ist jetzt auch ich habe auch
nur meine diamant spitzhacke mit dabei
also nichts irgendwie mit eisen oder so
dass ich andere sachen da vernünftig
abbauen kann das schon risky gerade so
ich brauche mich ganz schnell runter
jetzt muss ich leider die diamant
spitzhacken ganz kurze time lässt wir
zurück bei dem die
[Musik]
sie immer alle blöcke ein fachkundiger
das ist so frech von denen ich habe
letztens ein video bei youtube gesehen
da wird so gezeigt wie endermann
eigentlich reden also dass die
tatsächlich wenn die quatschen dass das
sogar sinn ergibt das sind einfach so
die sagen und so und das ist aber dann
irgendwie auf entsprach auch gerne über
luca schon drin auf jeden fall macht es
auch keinen sinn euch jedoch eine teils
einzublenden halt die wir hier vor noch
auf jeden fall die künftig noch einmal
ganz kurz und wir gehen jetzt erst mal
wieder hier runter nicht runterfallen
zeigt acht und bann hier runter wir uns
[Musik]
interessant bleibt einfach da gm lg
mäßig wieder hier weiter vor hier einmal
runter hier runter dass sie hat der
letzte mal nicht so ganz geklappt
deswegen gehen wir mal ganz kurz die den
bruchsteinen setzen den hierhin zack
dann können wir hier nochmal bruchstein
hinsetzen und hier können wir sie runter
gehen und jetzt nur wieder in der halle
angekommen
ganz kurz die vorne die sachen zu bauen
ich nehme jetzt auch wieder die kohle
hier mit so dass wird deshalb tauschen
können gegen smaragde mir vorne erst mal
die komplette lava zu bauen so dass wir
hier auf jeden fall unsere ruhe haben
hier setzen wir noch eine fackel dran
und hier vorne auch und jetzt können wir
uns auf die diamanten konzentrieren also
wir haben 12 345 diamanten blöcke
abgebaut haben allerdings 13 diamantweg
unser glück spitzhacke mein gott die
effekte die lager geführt
so wird sie das gar nicht lesen wir
vorne noch mal eben das reisen mitnehmen
und runter das also auch noch die total
schiss dass hier von irgendwo jetzt
gleich lava ausgeflossen kommt aber hier
scheinen wir auf jeden fall sicher zu
sagen hier vorne haben wir auch noch was
zeigt jetzt wieder hoch und ich
konzentriere mich jetzt wirklich erstmal
nur die diamanten denn ich will dass ich
meine diamant spitzhacke hier für ihn so
ein schwachsinn verwenden also wir haben
jetzt gerade aktuell 13 diamanten und
hier vorne haben wir 12 345 jammern
blöcke und insgesamt haben wir nun 28 es
ist auf jeden fall krass überlegt mal
wir haben aus fünf und nochmal vier
blöcken insgesamt hat aus neuen blöcken
28 diamanten herauskitzeln können dass
auf jeden fall brutal
ich habe zu meinen terminen sieben
minuten da werde ich überhaupt völlig zu
spät kommen allerdings möchte ich doch
so ein bisschen die hürde gerade
entdecken und ihr wisst ja dass man
dieses projekt extrem viel spaß macht am
liebsten würde ich jeden tag 40 minuten
video hochladen
da es allerdings dass sich das mit dem
schnitt wirklich nicht hinkriege weil
die folgen ja wieder extremen lang sind
ich weiß auch schon dass die heutige
folge obwohl ich zu beginn gesagt habe
dass sie ein bisschen kürzer wird das
jetzt auch schon wieder über 20 minuten
lang sein wird
deswegen noch mal eben ganz kurz das
hier mitnehmen einem ganzen es natürlich
wenn wir jetzt noch mal diamanten finden
würden und ich glaube auch wir haben in
der höhle hier wirklich eine menge glück
valuta oben gehen wir nicht hoch wir
müssen wirklich weiter runter und uns
laut und diamanten kümmern also ich
werde mich hier auf jeden fall noch mal
so ein bisschen umschauen
ich habe allerdings fast gar keine
steine mehr um mich weiter zu bauen
deswegen werde ich noch mal ganz kurz
ein bisschen steine abbauen und mich
jetzt hier vorne an der seite lang bauen
um hier auch noch mal zu gucken ob wir
eventuell einige diamanten haben
das wäre natürlich der absolute kracher
wenn wir jetzt irgendwie noch mal so
eine radler finden würden ich habe mir
auf jeden fall
34 34 diamant
das war wieder so klar dass ihr bruder
die lava cetto mein gott zum glück habe
ich dann eben die blöcke noch abgebaut
das habe ich nämlich schon mal gedacht
warum eigentlich immer nur die
diamantenabbau dieser form nicht schön
vielleicht haben ja die kabbala du lebst
echt völlig am limit alter wir haben
hier vorne einfach nochmal diamanten
gefunden was geht denn wer dieser höhle
ab aber gut freund ich weiß genau wenn
ich jetzt noch weitermachen werde dann
werden wir komplett sterben ich baue
hier fordern noch mal eben ganz kurz die
lava zu so dass wir es hier so ein
bisschen sicherer haben aber wir werden
hier auf jeden fall in der nächsten
episode noch so ein bisschen weiter
vorgehen es ist jetzt zwar nicht so eine
riesige furchteinflößende höhe wie die
letzten die wir entdeckt haben
allerdings ist die höhle extrem gut
bewandert was diamanten angeht und das
ist ja wirklich sehr geil ich sehe doch
schon hier vorne mit dem ganzen redstone
und so das nehme ich auch alles mit weil
dadurch bekommen wir erfahrung und die
kohle nämlich auch immer mit dem kohle
können wir halt eintauschen gegen
smaragde also hier vorne noch mal eben
kurz das redstone abbauen und dann werde
ich die heutige episode minecraft mit
luca an der stelle jetzt auch beenden
meine lieben freunde mir hat es sehr
sehr sehr sehr viel spaß gemacht wir
haben zwar nicht so viel geschafft also
wir waren eigentlich nur jetzt hier kurz
in der höhle kurz nach hause gefahren
geguckt aber alles noch steht und jetzt
ein video und jetzt wieder in die höhe
gefahren allerdings ist es ja so geil
mit den diamanten
lian li na gut genug
allerdings ist es ja sogar ja sogar die
mit den ganzen diamanten hier vorne geht
es noch weiter ich will am liebsten die
ganze zeit hier weiter entdecken gemerkt
auch schon ich hab eigentlich grad schon
die folge beendet
allerdings laufe die ganze zeit noch
weiter durch weil ich halt wissen will
ob wir hier noch mehr diamanten haben
also das wird jetzt auf jeden fall die
längste verabschiedung die je getätigt
hat mit dem kompletten projekt bisher
aber wenn es euch gefallen habe freunde
das gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem
video hier da abonniert main kanal falls
noch kein teil der luxus seitenwänden
und klickt dann auf die glocke dann
bekommt eine benachrichtigung sobald ich
ein neues video hochladen
ich habe mir vorgenommen demnächst mal
wieder ein bisschen mehr auch andere
sachen neben einfach hochzuladen wir
haben zwar dieses minecraft projekt hier
und ich merke auch und das macht mich
ein bisschen traurig dass andere videos
die ich hoch lade deutlich mehr discs
bekommen als minecraft also als wenn mir
wirklich die leute die zuschauer sagen
wollen luca laden nur minecraft hoch
alles andere finden wir scheiße das
finde ich halt ein bisschen blöd weil
ich ja schon immer auf youtube das
gemacht habe worauf ich lust habe und
das nimmt einem natürlich so ein
bisschen den spaß an andere sachen
gehärtet werden
deswegen würde ich mich freuen wenn ihr
auch anderen format eine chance geben
ich habe zum beispiel überlegt könnte
mir auch mal die kommentare schreiben
demnächst mal wieder mit sims anzufangen
da hätte ich total bock drauf aber
schreiben das gern und in die kommentare
schreibt mir bitte auch gerne unten in
die kommentare
ob ihr tipps habt bezüglich trading weil
mir auch oft geschrieben wurde lukas
macht keinen sinn dass du deine diamant
spitzhacke immer wieder repariert
mit diamanten das ist total teuer hol
dir einfach dies oder das oder blau aber
ich kenne mich damit nicht aus also
schreibt mir gern und in die kommentare
wenn ihr da tipps habt ich möchte das
weder jetzt allerdings nicht noch länger
machen als es eh schon ist weil ich das
ganze jetzt noch schneiden mussten
jedoch schon hier schon wieder so eine
risiko lada ich nehme das allerdings mit
mit dem willicher zu traden also freunde
ich habe mich ganz doll lieb ich brauche
noch ganz kurz eben die kohle ab würde
das wieder darsteller dagegen schon mal
beenden wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder
um 20 uhr im neuen video minecraft mit
luca ich hoffe ihr freut euch dort
werden wir dann
mit dem village ein bisschen traden sie
werden nach hause fahren und jetzt habe
ich auch die pole fast schon komplett
abgebaut von er kann ich das video ist
doch normal wenn du du hast die letzten
drei worte
[Musik]